Teens are often characterized as angsty, impulsive, socially inept citizens without fully formed brains,
straddling the worlds of being a child and
an adult, but how much of that is true?
More after this break.
You got a theme song?
Roll it!
That was the theme song?
Someone's getting fired.
Adolescence, the end of the
beginning of our lives,
or the beginning of the beginning
of the end of our lives.
Sorry, I was raised on My Chemical Romance. I've got a lot of, like, dark thoughts in my head.
Back in 3, 2...Adolescent development is
categorized by the onset of puberty and ends
when we choose our adult identity and behavior.
The ages that this occurs has changed over
time; people used to think it was 10-19 years old,
but new research suggests that the upper
limit is actually 24.
Why the change?
Well our bodies are still changing into our
20s and our brains don’t fully develop
also into our mid 20s.
But what does it even mean to be an adult?
Being emotionally sound?
Making good decisions?
A 9:30 bedtime?
Well, here are the Teens Are Dummies greatest
hits: “Teens Can’t Make Decisions,”
“Teens Are Impulsive,” and “They
Don’t Know Real Hip-Hop.”
None of those songs slap, but let’s break
them down.
“They Can’t Make Decisions” is the one
we all hear.
Got a lot of radio play earlier this year.
After the rise in student activism after school
shootings, people derided the kids saying
that they couldn’t make decisions that young.
But while the prefrontal cortex, the part
of the brain responsible for abstract thoughts,
decision-making, and social behaviors, isn’t
fully developed by high school age, it doesn’t
mean that kids aren’t ready to make decisions
about whether they want to live or not.
That’s survival instinct, we all have that.
And in this case it's tied directly
to traumatic emotions and memories, which
encompasses the limbic system,
the hippocampus, and, ding-dong, the prefrontal
cortex.Yeah, there are some decisions that
kids can’t make like whether or not to buy a certified
pre-owned hatchback, I mean,
you can't do it by yourself.
You got to get a guarantor on that.
But survival is something that people
of all ages can make decisions on.
Especially if it’s to stop future trauma
based on past ones. 16 year olds can see school
shooters in their school and be like, “yeah,
I don’t want that to happen again.”
They’re brains are formed enough make choices about wanting doctors, or breathable air,
or polar bears.
Man, I miss polar bears.
Older people’s main reservations about 16 year
olds voting surround their decision making,
whether they’re emotionally impulsive, and
that they don’t know how this country really
works...but, as we see, research suggests
otherwise.
At age 16, adolescent brains are still developing,
whereas older brains are begin cognitive decline
as early as age 45...soooo should there be
an age cap on voting?
Older people vote on issues that affect youth
currently who have much less power over the
future that they will have to live in....
just a thought.
And I get it,
The sentence “47th President of the United
States Danielle Bregoli” terrifies me, but
evidence shows that teens are getting smarter,
more active, and are energized.
And the science says that not only are we
ready to make those decisions, 16 could be
a better age to start forming civic engagement
and socially responsible habits as well.
“Teens Are Impulsive” is kinda reductive.
Yes, research suggests that younger people take
higher risks, are more impulsive, and their
limbic systems aren’t fully developed.
But this is because their social learning
is still being calibrated.
Adolescents tend to be bad at reading the emotions of others, but it takes time to learn how to
read all the complex social cues. And given the news
these days, it sounds like a lot of adults
run into those issues as well.
Studies show that by age 15, cold cognition,
or decision making based on facts rather than
emotions, is almost fully developed.
So, it’s possible that adolescents voting
at 18 is a-ok, possibly younger.
Millenials are eclipsing Baby Boomers as a
significant bloc in America’s electorate,
Generation Z is beginning to get the right to vote,
and if current social movements are any indication,
change is on the way.
With access to information, research suggesting
that they can be sound decision makers, and
the drive to make significant, impactful change,
I, for one, the first person in history
to ever have said this. No one else has said this.
Say that “the kids are alright.”
Trademark.
Here at Seeker, we share stories about science, technology, engineering and mathematics.
So make sure you come back
and watch more videos, see.
Thanks for watching.